I've never really been in the Furious
image someone that we saw dying is
actual alive but I came up to this
theory upon watching Game of Thrones and
to me this same theory is more than
convincing that with your mind has been
shared by many popular mainstream media
from experts UK to Metro UK the fear
itself is supported with quite a few
hints and clues that it made everyone
think twice about what they know or what
they thought they knew this is 7 in
provide us one more clue that is going
favor to net start being live and so I
decided to update this theory before
introduce you with this new hint and
clue let's first take a look on Clues we
had before about possibility of the most
honorable man in Seven Kingdoms Eddard
Stark being alive this whole time
this theory is not about possibility
let's start working into one of the
birds that flew above I mean the
execution scene or about anything that
has to do with working in this theory
Amanda was beheaded by sterling pain on
the steps of the great Sept of Baelor
was not actually net himself but was
jugging agar bear in Nets face I know
that at first it probably sounds
unbelievable but give me a few moments
explain it as we all know Eddard upon
trying to carry out the justice and
Robert's well was betrayed by slim and
Baelish whereupon he was imprisoned in
the black cells beneath the red keep
while at the same time there was also
joking hogar a mysterious man that was
introducing himself as a Loretto
criminal and who's also rested and put
into the dungeons
once he found out who'd already criminal
by the name of jack nico careles the
faceless man assessing we've all been
wondering why he got himself arrested we
know that he did it on purpose and got
himself in the dungeons clearly on
purpose well according to this theory
Faceman assassin was highly paid for his
service which in this case would be
helping Ned Stark to avoid a certain
death no it's somebody probably thinking
right now Jackie did not switch his face
with Ned he switched it with Syrio Forel
at this point you're probably confused
which I understand but just wait for a
couple of moments as we all know Syrio
Forel is a master swordfighter from the
free city of Braavos hired by Ned Stark
who trained his daughter Ari upon
discovering that his daughter owns a
sword upon its rest Lannister guard led
by Sir Manish went of the Kingsguard
came for her to take her into custody a
scene attended with your engaging sir
Marian with his wooden sword by this
theory theory did not die as he was
still far better with his wooden sword
and a dozen Leinster guards along with
ser Meryn Trant and according to this
theory she defeated him the evidence
supporting his part of a theory would be
a scene which the Hound left so hard on
our statement that she learned how to
fight from the first sword of Braavos
was apparently killed by Sir Marian
since her Marian was not great fighter
not even
so this point of the theory Ned Stark
and jocund were in their cells which
matches with Game of Thrones series
foster did not die as he was still in
King's Landing and so he decided to help
Ned Stark which could be questionable
but his theory Jahangir was arrested on
purpose which is most likely true since
I cannot imagine that the faceless man
could have been arrested against his
will
Jagan was arrested on purpose because of
Ned Stark in order to get into the
dungeon sent to help him and to
sacrifice his life for Nets it said that
for a good price the cult of religious
assassins that worship the many-faced
God will grant a gift of death to anyone
in the world but will they for a good
price suffered their own life for the
many-faced God the judge made history
did is also questionable according to
this theory Jackie huger faceless man
create a face that looked just like
Nance and worked on the day of Ned's
beheading which would mean that instead
of Ned it was Jackie who died who was
beheaded in the front steps of the great
Sept of Baelor as some kind of proof I'm
relying on a scene that took place in
the season 5 finale a scene in which
akiha garb or his face Volare herself
was standing just beside the scene might
be confirming that the faceless men
assassins can wear a face of person that
is not dead of a person that's still
alive since they might be able to create
a mask from other faces that would look
just like the face of the person they
want to portray if you're wondering what
was serious role it's actually pretty
simple
both the Jackie Nannette rested and
bring their cells which means that while
Jackie jugar was watching Ned and just
before he was beheaded someone had to
release net free and that someone also
had to replace Jackie and take Jackie's
face since a bit later we saw Jackie gar
being recruited by Orton to join the
Nights Watch so at this point Jackie
replaces Loretha criminal face Vanetta
face that he created himself violent
stark was released free from his cell
with the help of Syrio Forel which was
not that hard not to mention impossible
since first also could have done the
same if you want it
let's see what we got so far
Jackie's behead a Ned Stark is set free
but who - Jackie's former face of the
Loretto criminal continued to portray
him as we saw him being recruited by
urine and as we saw in helping Arya
numerous times it could be in by this
period as Syrio Forel which might be
hinted by the scene which one's the
many-faced God I see the stranger
I see the drowned God I see the way
would face there is only one guard
a girl knows his name there's only one
god and you know his name said jogging
to Aria which might be a confirmation
that Syria took face of a faceless man
that died for Ned took a face of jacking
Hagar this will explain my jogging told
waria that she already knows god's name
which she in fact knew because he
already told her during their training
series said to her there's only one God
and His name is death
if the Sarah comes showing the final
season it will also explain why Jackie
was so protective towards Ari and why he
learned her to become a skilled fighter
it would also explain how Jackie know
that Ari already knows the name of a
bunch o God the most importantly why
Jackie Hegar was smiling when Ari has
said to him a girl is Arya Stark from
Winterfell and I'm going home
upon rereading the books I've also found
some kind of header hints they're going
favor to this theory in which Jackie
Warren s face Samos beheaded the first
hint would be senseless claim that her
father's head above mangers holdfast
looked vaguely unlike her father the
second hint would be Catelyn stamen that
Ned's bones don't look like Ned's
but rather like someone smaller than net
and the last third hint would be are a
statement that Ned on execution they
look different which she thinks was a
result of Ned's injury that he got from
his confrontation with Jaime but let's
face it I've only leg doesn't change
your facial features I know that there
are still a few unanswered questions
such as who paid the faceless man and
various Ned hiding this whole time which
could be very simple considering a scene
from the very first season a scene in
which various visited imprison Ned from
that scene for the very first and last
time we saw her yelling at someone which
he did because he cared about Ed's life
but from that scene we also found out
from various that he was living in the
Free Cities tell the Queen you will
confess your vile treason tell your son
to lay down his sword and proclaim
Joffrey as the true heir the importance
of those facts that brought you a moment
ago is that very scared for his life he
did not release net himself because of a
simple reason everyone would have known
it was him which gave very slowly one
choice he had to pay to the faceless man
for his services while Syrio Forel
leader decided on his own to help Ned
door was arranged by Varys as well now
let's try the solo location of each ned
might have gone up on being released my
first guess would be the Free Cities or
more accurately the free city of Pentos
or even more accurate
as a guest of fillory embarrass verse
loyal friend there's also possibility of
Ned Stark upon being released stayed in
Westeros more precisely in gray water
watch the seat of house read whose head
is Howland Reed Nets loyal friend that
has already saved his life once and the
only man that beside Ned salmon brain
knows and kills John shew identity in
secret if you're wondering why am i
rejecting a possibility of net being
able to work into one of the words that
flow above him in the execution scene
well let's just put it this way
apparently the most important or should
I say the only argument that goes in
favor to the working theory is Ned Stark
being seen muttering to himself a moment
before he was beheaded now in my opinion
working in theory is ridiculous in my
opinion it was either the actual net who
mark to him sell the same price that he
was murdering just moment before he
executed well a deserter from the Nights
Watch or if a theory of mine comes true
it would mean the jacking while wearing
its face mark to himself all men must
die
Valar morghulis it was in fact the
actual net then Ned's last words could
even be I kept my promise as most of you
probably have already figured out at
this point
Ned whispering I kept my promise would
match with Lina's last words that she
whispered to Ned which were promised me
Navis bring to himself I kept my promise
would actually make a lot of sense as
Ned kept his promise that he gave to his
dying sister which was the protectors
son whose father's Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen had protected lea Aniston by
keeping it a secret
resuming to pursue his sister's son as
his own bastard and by deciding not to
use his nephews birth name which Leona
whispered to him a few moments before
her death but rather named him after his
friend and mentor Jon Arryn as a surname
would have given away John's real
parentage with all of this being said
Ned muttering to himself I kept my
promise most certainly is not beyond the
realm of possibilities and I'm sure most
of you would agree as a reward I already
mentioned ninth episode of the first
season as I was reporting as less words
that he might do himself it really does
seem like man's last words were valid
morghulis all men must die as much as
Ned Stark saying a greeting in high
Valyrian language that is common in
Braavos sounds ridiculous it might be
hitting him that Ned Stark is actually
alive because he naturally said whether
Magoo is before his beheading it might
be some kind of proof that is going
favor to my theory that I brought you
over a year ago now let's take a look on
the new hint that season 7 provided it
doesn't like him should have been caught
by someone who knew his face I have
already mentioned that in the books are
claims that on the execution day her
father looked different which he thought
was a result of an injury
Sensa claims that her father's head
about mingers whole face looked
unlike her father and even Catelyn said
that Ned's bones don't look like Ned's
but rather like someone smaller than it
and now in season seminary claims that
Ned statue doesn't look anything like
her father is it some kind of a
shadowing has this scene been written
this way to make a connection between
the books and the show isn't that surely
alive we'll have to wait for the final
season we'll get some of these answers
but certainly an interesting theory